It's working, fully operational and human words are coming out.
Hi!
I'm Mr. Wolfdog.
Old Spice was looking for someone to market their new wild collection of scents.
Someone from the wild, and I guess that's me.
Director Wolfdog, New Executive Director of Marketing.
Did you notice I have this cliche businessman decorations?
I have them to show...
...I am definitely successful in business and definitely not just a wild animal.
Also, look at this calculator.
Would a dangerous wild animal use a calculator?
I think not.
You see, I fully understand marketing.
Wild Collection Smell products.
Boom!
You've been seduced by my marketing.
That's marketing that I just did to you,...
...and it's how I get business done.
Stamp, stamp, stamp!
I just made a million dollars.
That's what I just did.
Bring in more business looking awards.
Here's a tough one.
How does a business leader resist...
...the strong, stomach-oriented urge to eat his staff members?
The hard fact is you don't.
Where's John?
Sometimes you got to eat people, America.
That's how business works.
And that's why I'm successful.
Listen, my point is this, follow my twitters or read my blog writings...
...because I'm about to make Old Spice Wild Collection...
...the wildest brand in the world.
You're welcome.
Bring in the meat sacks!